HIS SURGERY ON HIS NECK.
NOW ABOUT TO MAKE HIS VEVEER ON.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS OVERTIME IN
RALEIGH, WE GOND
WIN IT 16 SECONDS INTO OVERTIME.
>> Darren: LOOK AT THE LOOK ON
THE HEAD.
COUPLE GOOD LOOKS ON THE POWER D
SHOW.
BURAKOVSKY TURNS IT OVERLL.
PACIORETTY CLEARS IT OUT.
A FOOT RACE.
KARLSSON GETS THERE.IS SHOT OFF,
IN PLAY,.
>> Jamie: THAT PLAY WAEMPTING T
IT OUT
SKILLFUL PLAYS BEING
HIS DAD IS IN HERE ENJOYING HIS
FIRSRS CENTER, MARCHESSAULT.
HERE COMES DADONOV
JACK JOHNSON.
THTAPPING, LIKE YOU GOT TO PASST
TO ME.
YOU SAY, HEY,
MacKINNON TRACKS BIG
BODY.
NICHUSHKIN.
TIMING OFF A LITTLE BIT.
FRUSTRATION IN THE END.
IT WILL COME IN TIME WITH REGAR
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
GIVE THE GOALTENDER CREDIT.
>> John: BACK OF.
TOEWS.
KADRI, SPIN ON KARLSSON,N,
KADRI, TAKES IT HARD TO THE NET.
NOW MacKINNON.
JAILBREAK TO CENTER.
>> Jamie: GOODB BIT VEGA
FOR KARLSSON MANAGES TO KEEP
THE PUCK FROM GOING OVER
SHORT-SIDE STINGER BY GABRIEL
LANDESKOG AND IT'S COLOROR OFF
>> John: THIS ISE IN THE
THIRD.
YOU GOT SOMEBODY IN YOUR BACK
POK UP HAPPENING.
>> Jamie: VEGAS HAS KIND ALONG .
GOOD DEFENSE
FIVE-ON-FIVE SOMEWHERE IN THE 30
.
HE SCOOORES!.
BUT TH
WILL GO WIDE.
WILL SEND IT BACK.